well joining us now on our call-in set
is MSNBC's Chris Hayes who's written his
second book now and it's called a colony
in a nation mr. Hayes what did that
where did the name of that book come
from it's a line from a Richard Nixon
quote in 1968 he's giving his RNC
convention acceptance speech and he's
it's sort of thought of as the Law &
Order speech it's the most tumultuous
year in American political history in
recent memory and you've got riots
you've got protests you've got
assassinations and he's calling for a
return to order you know he said it's
time for some frank talk about the
problem of ordering them in the country
and there's a sort of kind of throwaway
line right he's talking about African
Americans and civil rights struggles and
says you know they want the same as
white Americans they don't want to just
be a colony in a nation and that term
what I encountered it while I was
reading that speech really stuck with me
and it seemed to capture something deep
about a lot of the reporting that I was
doing what where did this ring from was
there an incident that this book sprang
from I was you know we covered criminal
justice a lot of my show and we did that
even before Michael Brown's death and
before sort of the explosion of black
lives matter activism and what happened
in in in Baltimore but when I started
covering Ferguson and then Baltimore
that was the sort of catalyst as I was
sort of thinking about where the country
was at and what what was it about this
moment that was sort of producing this
kinetic reaction and and it started
thinking about sort of thing about why
we have built the system we built I mean
fundamentally the project of the book
and the project in writing it was trying
to get to the bottom of how we
constructed the
the policing and criminal justice system
constructed in your book you coming back
to Ferguson quite a bit they've had
quite an impact on you yeah you know I
grew up in the Bronx I go to New York
City I'm a city kid I grew up in New
York City in the 80s 90s when this
borough the the city in the borough were
much more dangerous there was much
higher crime so I had always thought
about these issues about police and
policing and friction as kind of big
city issues and I think part of what
really struck me in Ferguson was here is
this essentially anonymous Hamlet
municipality it's a suburb it's just
over the border but it's a small place
it's a place that people largely passed
away to go from the city of the other
places 20,000 people and everything that
was intense and fraught about policing
was in this small place and boiled down
in this kind of incredible essence and
there's something about the intensity of
it that that really stuck with me you
take on communities
are you a fan you know the problem part
of the problem with community policing
is that the term it gets really
stretched broken windows gets really
stretched to in fact the what broken
windows means is it means about 50
different things depending on who you're
asking
the idea behind community policing is an
approach in which police are in
communication and dialogue of community
about what kind of what the community
wants how a community wants to be
policed now at some level you know
policing is a matter of the law but it's
actually a lot more complicated than
that
turns out right so in any law
enforcement schema we select a level of
enforcement and that level of
enforcement can be driven by a lot of
things for instance it can be delivered
by budgetary constraints right like we
could catch every speeder in America if
we wanted to it would be within our
power but that would probably cost a lot
more money than we then were willing to
pay on it well community policing is at
its best is a dialogue and partnership
between police and communities about the
norms and order that the Pope that the
community itself wants desires and how
police can work with the community to
achieve that level of security and you
write that the problem with community
policing then and now is that so often
the cops being called to enforce
community norms are not part of the
community that's exactly the issue right
so we talk about community policing you
have a situations particularly since the
1980s and since the sort of rise of
broken windows as a model there's a real
focus on order preservation that's the
term that order maintenance is a term
that they use in the broken windows
article there's this real focus on order
maintenance and the problem is that
order is a very subjective thing so if
you walk through Madison Wisconsin where
this campus here at USA on a Saturday in
the fall you're gonna see what looks
like a lot of disorder
right college football game day is loud
drunken people are getting really are
consuming alcohol and all sorts of
places when I lived in Madison briefly
one fall it was you know couches were
outside there were people passed out
that looks like disorder that community
has decided that that's part of the
order of that community and it's
tolerated and so when you have an
outside force that's going to make those
determinations about what is and what is
tolerated and not tolerated a disorder
you're gonna end up in the situation
very intense conflict this all comes
back to race in your view yeah I mean I
don't know if it all comes back to it
but it's inescapable in the sense that I
think actually some of these issues
transcend race in some ways like these
questions about policing are fraught
questions in communities that are
essentially all-white their front
questions in societies that don't have a
lot of racial diversity there's a
certain degree to which people at the
margins of society or people who are in
densely packed areas of poverty in
whichever society they're in have
friction with the police this is a you
know you can you can read about it in
lame is and things like that right so
it's there's some parts of it that are
elemental the particularity 's of
America and particularity z' of what we
have constructed which is the largest
prison industrial complex in the world
the most intensely imprisoned state in
the world which is but crazy to think
about land of the free home of the brave
in that respect that decision to
construct that system I think is
inescapably about race this is book TV
on c-span 2 and MSNBC's Chris Hayes is
our guest his book a colony in a nation
is what it's called and if you want to
participate in our conversation this
morning here's how you can do so here
are the numbers 2:02 is the area code
seven four eight eighty two hundred if
you live in the east and central time
zones seven four eight eight two zero
one for those of you in the
and out here in the Pacific time zone as
well we'll begin taking those calls in
just a minute Chris Hayes what's your
take on this that you write in the book
the drop in crime in the u.s. from 92
through today is one of the most
stunning statistical and sociological
mysteries of our time you know when I
started commuting down in Manhattan in
1992 to go to high school there were
like 2,300 murders in New York City that
year last year there are about 300 think
about some other metric reduced by that
much carbon emissions child poverty car
accidents I mean it's it's a remarkable
thing that happened in this country and
it's a sort of to act story Act one as
1966 1992 there's an increase in crime
across all categories and across the
entire country big cities small cities
particularly white city's black cities
like this crime increases sort of shows
up in every statistical category and
then starting in 1992 the trend reverses
and similarly sort of goes away
everywhere and the cause for that the
basic story about what happened there is
still incredibly poorly understood it
you know ultimately I think that the the
best cases I've read are that it was
sort of multi-factor there's a
demographic component a component it had
to do with the drug war and the nature
of the drug war on the structure of drug
markets particularly around the
introduction of crack cocaine there's a
story about incarceration itself which
in the beginning probably did reduce the
crime rate there's a story about lead
possibly and the the the prevalence of
lead for the period of time that
produced this sort of cohort that was
committing the most crimes but the fact
the matter is we don't have a great
handle and we certainly don't have a
sort of granular and comprehensive view
and so the people that think they have
figured it out which are police
departments of major cities who live
through it and - they're you know I say
this with tremendous respect because if
you were in oversaw a crime decline like
that you would think you had unlocked
the
like something profound there is
emanated from that a kind of
superstition a kind of cargo cult a kind
of rain dance approach which is that
this fear that if you stop doing the
thing that you were doing yesterday then
the battle days will come back and we've
seen this the politics of that play out
very very intensely in places like
Chicago and Baltimore which have
experienced pretty significant and and
really worrying up ticks and violence
last years Chris Hayes is our guest and
Ruth is calling in from Flagstaff
Arizona go ahead Ruth we're listening
hey uh I'd like to ask Chris what he
would ask President Trump if he were
able to interview him in person you know
I think I would say something I would
ask him to walk me through the basics of
his health care plan or walk me through
the basics of his tax reform I think he
seems like incredibly hard-pressed to
give any granular details at all or even
just broad brushstrokes of his policies
and I think that it would be
illuminating and helpful in a sustained
setting to actually have him attempt to
talk through what his policy vision is
Rashaad Norfolk Virginia hi Rashad
you're on book TV
when hello Chris how you doing man um
congratulation with your book
congratulation with your book my
question is um I wouldn't speak ill of
President Trump but you know the lack of
knowing how a system like this work
America works I'm not an ex-president so
I don't have really a tremendous amount
of advice to give mr. Trump or president
Trump all my thing is with his Attorney
General and how he's trying to implement
um you know have to stop trying to stop
of crime and look and he should he
should you know speak to the police
chiefs about the lack of education and
the lack of interaction with the police
the police has a tendency to use Gestapo
tactics when they come like police stops
or transit stops they are using police I
mean on Gestapo tactics um I mean it's
brutalizing the citizens yeah and and
you know I dad read there has the see
yeah you know there's a there's a bunch
of think it's funny that he says that
term to Gestapo tactics because that is
a infamous pronouncement from the floor
of the convention hall in Chicago in 68
which of course was the other convention
that year famous much more famous than
what happened to Miami the the Gestapo
tactics by the the city's police of
course Mayor Daley who used that term no
it was a critic of Mayor Daley who said
it was also Mayor Daley who said the
police are not there to cause disorder
there there preserve disorder which is
an amazing quote as well point you know
Jeff Sessions has essentially put a hold
on a variety of consent decrees that
have been negotiated and are entered
into under the Obama administration
those consent decrees would emanate
usually from patterns and practices
investigations of systematic civil
rights violations by police departments
in major cities they include Chicago and
Baltimore and Cleveland among others
and he has basically put a put those on
hold a judge went ahead implementing
Baltimore's even without the DOJ is sort
of thumbs up and I think that Rashad is
right that it there's a really something
really worrying about an attorney
general whose perspective on these
issues seems to be a real step backwards
from your book in the world's most
punitive criminal system the application
of punishment is uneven in the extreme
black men aged 20 to 34 without a high
school degree have an institutional rate
of about 37% for white men without a
high school degree it's 12 percent or 3
times lower Hopewell Virginia Damon go
ahead hello am I on we are listening
please go ahead okay um I was just
wondering there are different issues
that sort of disproportionately affect
African Americans or people of color and
I'm wondering how to get white America
to maybe sort of feel like they have a
stake and whether or not something is
wrong with the black community right for
example white Americans none Krishna why
Americans live in poverty 24% of black
Americans live in poverty stuff like
that someone on how to get white America
to care about issues that are
specifically relating to black America
Damon we'll get an answer from Chris
Hayes in just a second tell us very
quickly about yourself about myself
yep oh I was just the african-american
millennial big Hillary Clinton supporter
of Democrat all my life you know the
standard probably black the standard
black person as far as voting and things
of that nature all right thank you sir
you know in some ways the project of the
book is to do precisely that
it's to
get what America in some ways to care
about these issues I mean one thing I
would say and something I say in the
book is a even if you just look at white
America the incarceration rate is still
incredibly high it's massively
disproportionate as as you just noted
but if you just took white America we
would still have one of the most
incarcerated countries on earth if you
just look at police shootings of white
people its way higher than other
countries we have huge amounts of sort
of social ills relative to other
countries even if you just isolate for
white people in this country and one of
the things that about this moment that I
think is really interesting is we are
seeing with this experience of really
intense profound economic distress
material decline along large swathes of
white working-class America particularly
as the opioid epidemic gets more intense
a real question about whether we're
going to use the sort of toolkit that
was developed on people of color and and
sort of ratchet up get get tough
language and mandatory minimums and
launch a new war on drugs or we're gonna
take a different approach and I think in
that way I think you know everybody has
a stake in the outcome of that because
everyone's kind of sort of rise or fall
together depending on what decisions we
make is there similarity between the way
the opioid epidemic is being treated and
the crack epidemic of the eighties it
was very either as a great New York
Times piece on this and something you
saw in the campaign trails the rhetoric
has been entirely different the rhetoric
around crack was unconscionably
dehumanizing it was it was crack babies
and you know
that that these people were brains were
rotted and the sort of demonic forces
that were gonna come and you know beat
you up and kill you to get a hit of
crack and all sorts of myths were
propagated for instance the idea that it
was more addictive than powder cocaine
which is not true that gave rise to
crack and cocaine sentencing disparities
right but it was a more intense drug
what I think has happened is that the
the language around opioids is far far
more empathetic far more about treatment
I think it's race I think it's largely
race I think crack was understood as an
issue of black people it was it was
coded as an issue of black people in the
inner cities it it it was allowed this
sort of dehumanizing rhetoric to to
flourish and you know you saw on the
campaign trail whether it was Chris
Christie or Ted Cruz or others opioids
is my cousin my brother my friend my you
know my grandchild and it's had a real
effect in the rhetoric now the question
and I think the really test is whether
the the rhetoric transfers into policies
that are different because I think
there's a big temptation actually right
now to sort of relaunch a new war on
drugs that would be just as destructive
as previous iterations let's hear from
Margaret and Leavenworth Kansas Margaret
you're on book TV with author Chris
Hayes yes thank you very much for your
TV show and your book I think we have
lost humanity in our country since the
Vietnam War I don't think we've ever
healed and we've been in one war after
the other and to have a war to drop the
mother of all bombs on other human
beings and and kind of be cheerful about
it to do the horrible things that we
keep doing as the world becomes closer
and sees this it's it's an absolute
despair to lock people up you have to
label them first and have a people that
work in prisons and I said to them
haven't you seen the people how many
you say or are mentally ill or got
mentally ill since they were placed in
there and then they laugh and say oh
well at least fifty percent of them and
I'm like so that's the way we treat
people instead of having care and it's
very easy to become labeled and now we
have a dangerous president that you know
labels women are going to be put so back
anybody that's low they face laughs at
education science everything good that
would unite music that brought people
together we have lost all that and
continual war continual war somewhere
but I think we got the point let's hear
from Chris Hayes you know I think that
there's a there's a continuity between
how America chooses to incarcerate its
own citizens and how it conducts itself
internationally I think there is the
sort of animating forces or fear and
punitive Ness toughness there's there's
this constant obsession with toughness
get tough on crime get tough on drugs
tough on foreign adversaries or
counterparties I think that that is
something woven in too deeply into
American cultural DNA and I think you
see it you I think Margaret is exactly
right that there's a connection between
the fact that we are a country that has
been in a state of near perpetual war
for four decades I mean we've been in
the longest war in the history of
Republic since 2001 grinds on to this
day and the incarceration rates I think
there's something to that
Carol Fairfield California Carol go
ahead hi Chris I'm a great fan what made
you write your book and do you get your
Brooklyn help the racial divide in this
country well I I don't think any book is
gonna do that and I don't think that any
signal act is gonna do that and in some
ways I don't even think that there's
some sort of final thick state where it
will be solved I think it
it's a sort of a kind of eternal and
continuous work for the for American
society in American citizens what made
me want to write it was just a feeling
that I thought I had some perspective to
offer because of how how I'd grown up in
the city at the time I had and what I
sort of experienced firsthand and what
I've reported I thought I could offer
some insight into the sort of that
question about how the system was built
and why we built it and that and that's
part part of the sort of project the
book is getting people to ask themselves
that question when they think about the
politics even the language of of crime
and justice and policing is there a
relationship between this book in your
first book the twilight of the elites I
think there is because they're both
books about attempting to sort of
diagnose what I would say are sort of
democratic failures right failures of
our democratic ideals all the democratic
ideals and I think that they there in
some ways they're sort of in an
interesting dialogue with each other in
that respect Jeff Littlefield Arizona
please go ahead Jeff
I've seen that changes over the years
and when you're certain places in
situation they can be but they need Jeff
I apologize it's a bad connection we're
gonna have to let you go I don't think
either of us could hear that very well
and let's try to see if we can get in
Mallory in Naperville Illinois Mallory
you're on book TV with Chris Hayes we're
listening I'm hi thank you to a book TV
and hi Chris
I saw you in Chicago when you had a book
discussion with Natalie Moore and I I
must admit the more at the point that
you get your book discussion I was about
I don't know it's it's very the way
through I'm now halfway through the more
I read the more depressed I get
it is it's not a I don't know what I
expected but it's getting me more and
more depressed and specifically I'm at
the point or I'm at the part where
you're talking about white fear and I
was wondering if you could expound on
because I think that's the root of all
of this it's white it's white fear all
right and before you do I just want to
read one line from your book which is
Americans convert white fear into policy
yeah her point Mallory's point that I
one of the theses of the book is that it
is sort of foundational that you know
the first the captain of the ship that
lands at Jamestown the first entry is we
were set upon by the savages and from
that moment all the way through the
experience of settlement the frontier
the the project of slavery and the
incredible amount of sort of fear and
terror that required and the constant
fear of the slave revolt of the of the
social order spinning out of control but
that is something really deeply woven
into our political and cultural DNA and
it's a it's a part of who we are as a
people because of the sort of
foundational ways in which the country
was constructed and we share it we pass
it along from generation to generation
and politicians find new ways to sort of
exploit it Chris Hayes in a colony in a
nation you conclude with the story of
about four black boys on bicycles very
quickly what is that story and did you
call the police the final story is just
about pausing while I saw some boys 11
12 on the precipice of adolescence dude
we're sort of acting the fool and they
grabbed someone's iPhone and they sped
off on their bikes and I stopped to call
the police sort of think about doing it
the book ends on me just holding the
phone and the reason I wanted to end on
that was because I think that part of
the effect of doing the reporting I've
been doing it right in the book was to
think really carefully about what are
the costs of involving the police in a
situation and that's not something I had
ever really deeply grappled with before
but it's something that millions of
people grapple with every day obviously
and and I want to try to communicate to
people what it feels like or or for them
to understand that there's a cost to
policing did you push the button gotta
read the book Chris Hayes a colony in
the nation is the name of the book his
show all in with Chris Hayes airs at
8:00 p.m. Eastern Time on MSNBC during
the week